[Music]
we're dealing
with the suckiest year in my lifetime
2020 where the year where you learned
that maybe you weren't essential
that's that's can you imagine how how
damaging is that micro was talking about
that when he was here yeah
you know i there's just this occasional
line somebody drops and it just
it just wormholes in my brain and when
mike rowe was here a few weeks ago and
he mentioned
that we just told 300 million people in
the united states you know what y'all
just stay home you're not essential
i just the the mental health
person in me just it was a neon sign it
was a big bell that i couldn't unhear
which we
don't need you we don't you have no
value just stay home
we'll call you man we are made to work
but more importantly we are purpose
driven beings
that's just what we do and when somebody
just looks in the eye when your
government looks you in the eye let me
just tell you says you're not important
ramsey solutions thinks you're essential
that's why we're still here doing this
show that's exactly right
we think your marriage and your wealth
building and your kiddos
and your career and your mental health
is essential
and that's why we're here because we
think
you're amazing we love people we even
love those of you a little crazy and
some of you are a little crazy i'll just
tell
you i get some emails some of y'all are
are awesome
some of them are beat little crazy but
all the way up to big crazy but that but
most people are just going to oh
man everybody's got yours you're
essential
yes yes you're essential so i did figure
out though as an
employer and our people working from
home or are people sheltering at home or
our people whatever
and talking to some of our government
officials they um they said
well we thought you guys were essential
and i after talking around a little bit
i kind of figured out
what the essential industries were
it's it's a fairly easy idea what is
that you just decide you are
i'd say because nobody had a real
definition
that com that but that works in our
individual lives right
i'm essential screw it i am worth being
respected
in this relationship i am worth dignity
at my job
not me honestly they don't have a
definition wow
they didn't have one huh i mean so
you know what is essential i decided i
am so so everyone it's you
you're all essential right you just
decide you are decide you're essential
or decide you're not and stay home if
you want but that's okay
there's always a place for people who
want to wear their bathing suits and eat
cheetos and just call it
cash it in man you know what i mean
have more dignity than that
you're worth something you're worth
something that's it i could rant on that
all day